c'est un 22h48 heure de l'est que david
saint-jacques doit toucher terre au
kazakhstan après avoir passé plus de six
mois dans la station spatiale
internationale
le retour sera périlleux au sol les
équipes d'urgence se prépare à toute
éventualité parce que le bestiau soyouz
va atterrir dans une région très isolée
tamara on a mis des heures et des heures
à rouler sur les routes de terre et de
ça pour arriver ici à notre destination
finale en plein coeur des steppes du
kazakhstan est absolument rien autour de
nous mais c'est un vaste terrain où on a
identifié très sites potentiels ou
pourrait se poser là soyouz ce soir
meilleur quand je voudrais pour nous ce
serait à quelques mètres et c'est fort
possible
juste devant nous pire des scénarios à
une trentaine de kilomètres ça va
dépendre des éléments du vent par
exemple mais les conditions sont
excellentes aujourd'hui le ciel est
dégagé
il fait 38 degrés au sol c'est chaud
pour nous mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
les températures infernales que
l'équipage la suze vont connaître alors
qu'ils vont pénétrer l'atmosphère les
couches atmosphériques de la terre on
parle de température qui frise les 2000
degrés c'est d'ailleurs une des
manoeuvres les plus sérieuses et plus
intense de la descente
ça c'est pour plus tard pour le moment
ça y est david saint jacques et ses
collègues sont à bord de la ssi use on a
fermé la porte et à 19h24 exactement
heure de l'est elle se détachera de la
station spatiale internationale et
commencera cette descente qui dure à peu
près une heure et nous à partir du
moment où on pourra la voir on nous dit
que ce sera quand il sera à 10 km de la
terre on pourra la voir apparaître avec
ses parachutes et c'est pour ça que
c'est ici un peu le centre névralgique
de l'opération de secours un convoi
d'hélicoptères disque iront à sa
rencontre
pas seulement au sol mais dans les airs
pour l'assister dans sa descente finale
et aidé ensuite à extirper les
astronautes de la capsule les médecins
seront sur place donc atterrissage prévu
à 22h48 55 secondes exactement c'est
réglé au quart de tour
merci tamara à plus tard au revoir